[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
point de vue je vous présente les deux
invités qui ont accepté d'y participer
jérôme sainte marie bonjour bonjour vous
êtes politologue et fondateur de la
société pôle inbox est votre dernier
livre bloc contre bloc la dynamique du
maquereau nice est paru aux éditions du
cerf en 2019 face à vos mathieu soupière
bonjour bonjour aux élus ce consultant
expert associé à la fondation jean
jaurès alors deux thèmes aujourd'hui qui
ont retenu notre attention
le premier c'est le vote par
anticipation est ce que c'est un déni de
démocratie et le second thème michel
barnier peut-il être le sauveur de la
droite en 2022
on démarre tout de suite par le premier
thème donc en fait c'est réglé puisque
l'amendement qui a été déposé par le
gouvernement pour essayer d'organiser le
scrutin présidentiel et de prévoir la
mise en place d'urnes
une semaine avant le scrutin pour
permettre un vote par anticipation
le sénat a voté contre malgré tout ça a
provoqué une levée de boucliers je vous
propose d'écouter bruno retailleau il
était sur public sénat nous avons été
absolument stupéfait lorsque ce matin
nous avons appris que le gouvernement
déposé cet amendement
à nouveau on essaie finalement de
fausser le jeu ou en tout cas on est sur
des magouilles politiciennes alors qu'on
est encore en crise sanitaire et je
pense que ça dénote un mépris profond en
tout cas une légèreté insoutenable
vis-à-vis de la chose démocratique
et nous allons écouter maintenant
christophe castaner ancien ministre de
l'intérieur et député
lrm qui prenait la défense du
gouvernement c'était sur france 2 vous
l'objectif est de faire baisser la
tension
à chaque élection présidentielle dans
l'année qui précède il y ait une loi qui
met en place de nouveaux dispositifs et
le gouvernement proposera par amendement
ce sera débattue aujourd'hui au sénat
la possibilité d'avoir dans certaines
villes la capacité de voter par
anticipation j étais dans quelques jours
si ça permet de donner la possibilité de
voter à des personnes qui ne pourraient
pas ou que ne leur ait pas été voter je
pense que c'est important et puis nous
sommes aussi aujourd'hui encore dans le
schéma d'une gestion de crises
sanitaires autant l'anticiper avant de
parler du fond qui est quand même
important juste pour la forme sur la
forme
un amendement déposé comme ça un peu
presque subrepticement par le
gouvernement au sénat alors que le texte
a été voté par l'assemblée nationale
qu'est ce que ça révèle selon vous
matthieu sinclair alors soit un
amateurisme politique mais après quatre
années quand même de gestion le procès
est un peu rude soit effectivement une
forme de déni parlementaires parce que
sur le fond la question est tout à fait
sérieuse elle mérite un vrai débat
il n'y a aucune raison d'ailleurs de
balayer la question d'un revers de main
sur la forme ça paraît tout à fait
absurde
ceci est en face à l'amateurisme on
entendait la bruno retailleau à
l'instant parler de magouille politique
politicienne
je suis pas sûr que ce soit au niveau
contester une méthode c'est une chose
mais évacué en fait un sujet qui est un
vrai sujet démocratique dans le contexte
avec ces termes là avec ces mots là le
mode magouilles magouille politicienne
c'est normal normalement pas en fait une
rhétorique emploi la droite
traditionnelle
je trouve que c'est un peu à côté de la
plaque et pas du tout à la hauteur du
sujet jérôme sainte marie c'est vrai que
ce gouvernement depuis 2010 est nous a
pas vraiment habitué à aménager le
parlement oui alors moi je suis un grand
partisan de l'usagé du mot magouilles
si vous voulez je trouve que c'est le
rôle des politiques de se surveiller de
surveiller mutuellement s'appelle la
démocratie et des magouilles il y en a
c'est même toute personne et là c'est le
cas tout praticien
on doit ces rien alors moi je gagne si
vous voulez on va et je vais me faire
d'abord l'avocat du diable le diable est
dans les détails de ce petit détail il
ya effectivement un problème qui dans la
démocratie habituel advocacy française
qui tient au phénomène non pas les loups
d'inscrits qui sont à peu près 9 % du
corps électoral
mais de ce qu'on appelle parfois les
mâles
inscrits j'avais écrit un article dans
le figaro imaginez-vous il ya cinq ans
avec le professeur jean-yves dans ma
jeunesse sur ce phénomène des mâles
inscrit on a environ 7 millions de
personnes qui ne sont pas inscrits dans
la commune où ils résident il y avait
des gens adorent magento professeur à
montpellier on avait calculé que les
gens qui sont mal inscrits en trois fois
plus de chances de s'abstenir que les
gens qui sont bien inscrits être bien
inscrit donc c'est le contraire c'est
d'être inscrit dans sa commune de
résidence
et même à paris par exemple dans les
villes où il ya des arrondissements
qu'on a inscrit dans un autre
arrondissement de la même ville que là
où l'on réside
les chances que l'on a de s'abstenir
sont extrêmement importantes
donc effectivement puisqu'on ne peut pas
rapproché autoritaire voire les gens de
leur bureau de vote
et là offrir la possibilité de voter
pouvait répondre à ce phénomène de mal
inscriptions alors aussitôt là l'idée de
magouilles à paris parce que pourquoi
parce que c'est mal inscrits on les
connaît il est étudié compris celles
qu'on a fait avec journée d'hommage 1
qui en montre le profil c'est souvent
des gens vous savez qu'ils sont
relativement fade et étudiants beaucoup
des jeunes et les jeunes étudiants votre
plutôt les jeunes veulent plutôt
rassurants nationale qui ne sont pas
étudiants mais quand ils sont étudiants
ils votent plutôt pour des partis comme
la réplique en marche ensuite qui est ce
qui est mal inscrits c'est très souvent
des gens qui ont une raison secondaire
parce que vous vous dites là où est ma
raison secondaire en normandie dans les
alpes ou ailleurs et bien si je suis
inscrit là bas je pourrait peser sur les
décisions de la commune et ainsi faire
en sorte que je sais pas moi le bus
s'arrête près de ma maison au contraire
que nos maisons ne soient pas encore la
gérance ce vote
ils votent l'udc vote mais réseau
secondaire à ils ont entre autres ont
d'ailleurs ils ont donc plutôt mieux
dotée financièrement et vous savez ce
que c'est un produit les a produits de
votre patron c'est assez simple en fait
la vie est donc effectivement il peut y
avoir un calcul à la marge et sachant
que l'élection 2022 s'annonce plus serré
que ce qui était anticipé
il est tout à fait possible qu'il y ait
eu un calcul président à cette
initiative désastreuse et que le terme
magouilles n'ait pas été utilisé
totalement au hasard que ça peut générer
du vote macro mais ça peut aussi générer
du vote barnier j'anticipe assure
l'adjoint vert à son père sur ce soit
une mécanique
mais sur le chemin que soupière seriez
d'accord s'il y avait cette mise en
place d'un vote par correspondance une
semaine avant un peu comme ça se passe
aux etats unis c'est pour ça que je
nuance ce que dit jérôme sainte marie
j'entends ces arguments néanmoins encore
une fois je pense que la critique
d'amateurs ps davantage que la critique
de magouilleurs alors amateurs politique
en ce sens qu'il ne pouvait pas ignorer
que la proposition faite à fortiori en
catimini puisse être interprétée par une
opinion déjà très des fientes comme une
forme de manipulation une forme
d'instrumentalisation ou de triche
larvée voilà ça c'est sûr en revanche
oui je comprends pas la double critique
qu'a fait d'ailleurs bruno retailleau
il a critiqué sur la forme en disant
magouilles politiciennes
il a critiqué sur le fond en disant
c'est contraire à la tradition à la
tradition française art effectivement
toute nouveauté par définition est
contraire à la tradition france le vote
des femmes comment il a été instauré et
est contraire à la tradition française
je trouve que là encore l'argument est
un poète un peu faible si c'est une
magouille que de réfléchir à
l'introduction de dispositifs que de
nombreuses démocraties dans le monde
applique déjà depuis longtemps son
difficulté particulière alors le scrutin
probablement américains de ces derniers
mois mise à part mais sinon globalement
démocratie tout à fait mature tout à
fait stable
en tout cas aussi peu critiquable que la
nôtre il passe depuis longtemps et ça ne
pose pas de difficulté donc a fortiori
encore une fois dans le contexte dans le
contexte où la houle alors j'ajoute un
élément à ce que disait jérôme
sainte-marie sur la sociologie
électorale
jérôme sainte-marie parle dans son livre
son dernier livre que vous avez cité en
particulier dû battre du votre retraités
qui constitue un rempart aujourd'hui au
vote front national
il est vrai que dans un contexte
sanitaire difficile où les regards
étaient eux mêmes peuvent craindre pour
leur santé ils peuvent être tentés de
s'abstenir et 7 abstentions
si elle était massive pourrait avoir un
impact non négligeable sur le scrutin ça
c'est le grand argument effectivement
pour lutter contre l'abstention en temps
de pandémie des villes ennemies ont fait
un votre part
par correspondance où va votre bandits
passion et ça permet aux gens de se
mobiliser ou alors tu es alors j'attends
j'ai entendu ça m'arrive n'est pas ça
vous fait sourire locuteurs deux
arguments en fait et non par un seul le
premier argument de vote école fera son
champion le second argument de votre de
lutter contre le vote
rassemblant nationale si j'ai bien
compris parce que est par ailleurs bond
moyson bien françois disruptive conçois
qu'on soit innovant etc
mais il ya un truc qui s'appelle je suis
désolé pour les gouvernants la
constitution intéressant la constitution
pas se faire à constitution il ya un
truc qui va voir des artistes là
notamment jeu le numéro m'échappe qui a
trait à la sincérité du scrutin
il faut le scrutin soit libre mais
également qu'ils soient égales qu'est ce
que ça veut dire en l'occurrence
pourquoi est-ce que j'en parle cette
sincérité du scrutin
si vous votez le lundi 6 jours avant le
comme ça vous pouvez c'était prévu par
l'amendement la semaine amiable c'est à
dire que va prendre le dernier scrutin
donc des gens j'ai plus les dates
exactement en tête mais certains
auraient pu voter avant le célèbre grand
débat macro le pen bon soit plus
favorisés madame le pen sans doute mais
si vous voulez vous avez donc c'est à
dire que des gens vont être on n'imagine
pas que le débat d'entre deux tour ait
lieu après en fait l'ouverture du box
ah bon j'imagine tout vous savez tout
est imaginable tout est imaginable et en
une fois les autres grandes démocraties
fondation sérieuse faut faire confiance
ils voulaient à l'avenir et à
l'imagination politique je vous assure
que tout est mis
on peut même afficher des gens sur les
opinions politiques mais depuis avoir
figé les gens trois options politiques
vous assure qu'il ya trois ans c'était
inimaginable place et imaginables et
donc non bien sûr tout est imaginable en
le monde et vous n'avez par ailleurs le
fait cette égalité
encore une fois ça c'est pas après une
déviation passe un problème de
constitutionnalité
le scrutin doit être sincère et donc les
votes il va inégalités c'est pour ça par
exemple que ont fait voter les gens des
territoires d'outre-mer les départements
d'outre-mer on les fait voter forcément
va pas changer les fuseaux horaires a si
vous voulez donc ils veulent re mais ils
ne connaissent pas ont clos les choses
les urnes se voyait son cv etc
on ne peut pas savoir en principe en
métropole on ne sait pas quel est le
vote des gens qui ont voté avant
par exemple donc c'est comme ça dans
toutes les démocraties où ce vote par
anticipation existe sur eux mais de
toute façon tout à sa tâche faut
réorganiser du coup signifierait de
leuven dans cinq sens à ce trouble
politique c'est à dire que on y aurait
des gens qui ont voté le lundi d'autres
le vendredi et d'autres enfin le
dimanche mais dans une semaine politique
surtout entre deux tours il se passe
énormément de choses
alors où est ce que ces problématiques
d'une parce que c'est comme la
constitution donc les principes ça
compte
et puis imaginons qu'on ait un résultat
électoral en 2022 qui soit très serré
macron l'emportent de justesse ou un ses
concurrents l'emportent de justesse
forcément et plupart et qu'il est de
toute façon au deuxième tour oui m'enfin
bref
imaginons il y aura un vote et trans cas
des candidats de second tour vous avez
raison soyons très prudent et bien à ce
moment là il y aura les gens n'auront
pas les gens qui ont été battus n'ont
pas envie de croire que l'autre l'a
reporté une fois ça aux états unis par
exemple la normale sébastien on a le
droit les citoyens ont droit d'être
mauvais joueur dans un endroit d'autres
de mauvaise foi on l'est tous donc à
partir de là
s'ils ont effectivement ce genre
d'argument dix ans en mai c'est
dégoûtant parce qu'il ya deux millions
de personnes qui ont voté alors que le
jeudi s'est passé on a découvert un truc
incroyable et bien ça ouvre lieu à la
contestation du scrutin
donc ça crée un trou de troubles à
l'ordre public et ça crée une défiance
voix démocrates seraient créés se drape
halima n'aura pas du corps créé avec
pardon on ne joue pas avec ça pour le
plaisir sera l'innovation à redon de
marteler l'armée jérôme est encore une
fois quand ce système est mis en place
en suisse en allemagne aux etats-unis au
canada ou ailleurs
personne ne conteste le bien-fondé
démocratique vous prenez l'exemple de la
petite dernière aux états unis à un tout
petit peu justement j'y viens le cil
affaire à à fait aux hôtes en polémique
aux états unis je pense que ça tient
autant à la personnalité de trump et au
discours qu'il a lui-même tenues mettant
en cause la sincérité du scrutin avant
même qu'ils se tiennent et les risques
de manipulation avant même encore une
fois que les votes s'opère je pense que
ça tient bien davantage à cela au
contexte au climat que le candidat
lui-même a créé car un système mal
organisé encore une fois dans tous les
autres pays c'est si ces scrutins
s'organise 2
manière totalement fluide et non
contestés par le par l'opinion alors
jusqu'à vous répondiez juste je vous
donne quand même la vie nos internautes
qui peuvent intervenir sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont d'ailleurs c'est la
question du jour
êtes vous favorable à la mise en place
d'un vote électronique anticipé à
l'élection présidentielle sur dix neuf
mille 500 votants ce qui est un bon bon
score de participation non à 65% et je
vous précise on n'avait pas mis en place
un vote par anticipation là ils ont voté
oui ont posé la question à redon mais
c'est un détail qui n'en est pas un on
ne parle pas de vote est électronique
on peut imaginer un vote par
anticipation qui soit un vote physique
tout en l'occurrence c'était la mise en
glace bien alors évidemment vote
anticipé votre par correspondance sont
les deux mamelles de la fraude selon
nicole qui nous dit aussi c'est comme si
nous avons répondu l'attention parce que
c'est l'enjeu c'est l'abstention
il faut en passer par le vote
obligatoire comme en belgique ça peut
être une piste aussi le vote obligatoire
mais pourquoi alors nous par
anticipation ou pas par anticipation
je pense que c'est une réponse
différente malgré tout mais si
l'objectif est effectivement de faire
baisser l'abstention le par définition
le vote obligatoire permet de faire
baisser la demande
il y a en tout état de cause une vraie
difficulté quand on voit l'abstention
croissante et y compris le niveau
qu'elle a atteint aux municipales
rappelons nous quand même qu'aux
municipales 55 % d'abstention au premier
tour et 58 de deuxième alors justement
l'abstention municipal c'était un cas
particulier ce colis delà il ya la
vaccination
donc normalement en 2022
on imagine la majorité de la population
sera vaccinée donc on n'aura plus ce
risque là les gens pourront aller dans
les bureaux de vote sans crainte
oui enfin si l'on a envie d'y aller
encore une fois le grand mystère en la
vie n'est pas de savoir et c'est un
sondeur un électoraliste qui vous parle
le grand milan à la vie politique n'est
pas de savoir pourquoi les gens
s'abstiennent c'est pourquoi ils vont
voter
en réalité c'est très curieux imaginons
alors je parle nous sommes fois
figuerola et imaginons que au second
tour le hasard des hurdes amène un
second tour entre yannick jadot et
olivier faure tout est possible vous
êtes gentils à effrayer nos ventes
obliger les abonnés du figaro quand on
regarde d'aller voter et choisir entre
et yannick jadot quelle violence au
liban
mais pourquoi non c'est rennes n'a pas
pu tenir c'est mieux de voter blanc d'un
point de vue républicain mais s'abstenir
c'est pas un péché si vous voulez
pourquoi est-ce qu'on verrait forcément
choisir entre des gens puis de nom mais
vous le dites vous même votre blanc et
dans ce cas de figure la halle est pas
rien parce que le vote alors tu es si
vous voulez prendre nos cerveaux de
comploter fondation jean jaurès unis
toujours dans une conversation par le
passé même qu'ils comprennent pas c'est
compliqué mais bon pourquoi pas donc il
n'y a pas de complot pas les parloirs
étalons ne pas leur faire français sont
gravement complotistes est depuis très
longtemps parce que imaginez vous qu'on
pratique plus le vote par correspondance
pourquoi parce qu'on a trouvé que gt gt
justement c'était quelque chose qui a
été qui pouvait porter atteinte à la
sincérité du scrutin et donc à la
confiance des citoyens dans l'élection
c'est pas rien le vote par
correspondance a été annulée pourquoi
mais encore une fois ça pose problème
par correspondance existe d'innombrables
démocratie où le niveau de défiance de
laurent vignaud est bien moindre qu'en
france et pour le coup des citoyens et
le rempart de la démocratie si voulez
mon avis pour lutter contre les fraudes
pour le coup que ce soit
une urne physique où les gens se
déplacent le jour-même vote électronique
vote par correspondance les risques sont
identiques on se souvient des
municipales de camera 3 sauf qu'on est
on est on est paniquée à l'idée que
l'outil numérique puisse s'immiscer dans
nos affaires démocratique on va pas très
bien pourquoi aujourd'hui avec
effectivement un outil numérique on peut
rencontrer son amoureux sont amoureuses
ont fait en gros on fait toutes ces
transactions quotidiennes avec ses
coordonnées bancaires en ligne on
déclare ses impôts on paye ses impôts
on se déclare à pôle emploi on se
déclare à la caf on fait tout ça est
évidemment que les affaires sont
sécurisés alors un bug une attaque un
sabotage est toujours possible mais
encore une fois une attaque est toujours
posée une attaque physique vers un
attentat sur un bureau de vote est aussi
toujours aussi intéressé vous au
référendum qui a eu lieu au début des
années 2000 je crois dans fin des 90 et
l'élection présentielle de 96 qu'en
russie et vous verrez que cette année je
me trompe peut-être et spécial action
list hâtives ou 96 il ya deux élections
à foix référendum sur la constitution
élections générales en russie qui était
gérée par des services américains et
qu'ils ont lus de le scrutin est entaché
d'un doute énorme parce que justement le
sait bien la russie c'est très grand
vous savez y ait des fuseaux horaires il
s'agira donc on vote avec le niveau
stoxx banques qu'elles sont c'est à
tourner mais donc beaucoup plus tôt je
pense que dans moscou le contraire est
vrai très plusieurs heures et le système
numérique faveur informatiques mises en
place par les américains c'était le pays
est très grand il fait très froid c'est
tout blanc et donc c'est tombé en panne
c'est pas de chance à l'étoile noire est
devenu tout noir en quelques heures et
quand le système américain s'est remis
en place et ben c'était bien parce que
les anti communiste avait faut qu'elle
le lui d'autres avaient avait remporté
l'élection le même que le mien sur les
élections on parle souvent du problème
des élections de l'affluence ce supposé
des russes sur les élections américaines
on ferait mieux de s'intéresser à n'a
pris aucun réel des américains
indexant s'éloigne on va revenir
peut-être sur au niveau européen et
d'ailleurs au niveau français puisque le
deuxième thème de notre émission de ce
soir c'est michel barnier peut-il sauver
la droite c'est une droite qui cherche
un candidat désespérément alors elle
pensait avoir trouvé son salut avec
françois baroin et ça ça n'a pas l'air
de
de l'intéressé plus que ça en tout cas
aujourd'hui certains misent sur xavier
bertrand d'autres sur valérie pécresse
et puis depuis qu'il ya eu un accord sur
le brésil c'est michel barnier qui
disponible s'est placé sur les rangs
alors un sondage est là dont vous allez
voir les résultats montrent que l'ancien
ministre n'est pas si mal placé à droite
même s'il reste largement méconnu de la
plupart des français donc 27 % des
français ont une opinion positive de
michel barnier 27% d'opinions négatives
mais c'est surtout 46% qui ne le
connaissent pas alors cela dit avec 27 %
il est plutôt bien placé parce qu'il est
devant bruno retailleau devant valérie
pécresse et françois baroin il est à
égalité avec xavier bertrand dont lui on
sait il a déclaré depuis longtemps
qu'ils étaient candidats derrière
sarkozy ou edouard philippe
alors est-ce qu'il peut être le candidat
qui sauvera la droite en 2022 genre
d'appareil alors je vous remercie ce que
je commençais un peu à m'échauffer sur
cette voie de scrutin
ouais la crise grecque avec l'hypothèse
de la candidature d un effet le calme là
c'est même un immense apaisement si vous
voulez oui pourquoi pas j'ai envie de
vous dire pourquoi pas alors c'est
intéressant dans notre point de vue
parce que déjà c'est très facile de
faire le lien entre l'apparition des
chaînes barnier et ce qui se passe
actuellement en italie
c'est à dire que l'italie et avait donc
les problèmes structurels de l'italie
sont aggravés spectaculairement par le
cos vie de 19 et que là ils ont après
avoir tenté des solutions qu'on
appellera par facilité populiste ça veut
pas dire grand chose est bien là au
contraire il ya un gouvernement d'union
nationale où pratiquement ou
pratiquement toutes les forces
politiques sont représentés sous la
direction de mario draghi qui lui
représente le contraire du populisme
puisque il a été commissaire européen
enfin la réflexion que ça paie de la
dette de la grèce et s'occuper donc des
grecs une certaine manière et donc il a
été en quelque sorte le voilà le
gouverneur de la grèce le proconsul de
l'union européenne là bas et maintenant
il se remplit la même tâche en italie
mais ça peut être intéressant pour de
faire ce comparatif par rapport à michel
barnier qui lui en fait et identifiée
par parfois en réalité parlera un peu
par son engagement politique beaucoup je
pense que les français qui s'en
souviennent par les jeux d'albertville
que car certains confondent avec jean
claude killy d'ailleurs et qui par
ailleurs
effectivement il a été un ministre
l'agriculture très populaire géniteur en
deux entre 97 et 99 me semble-t-il
il a fait il a beaucoup marqué les
esprits dans le monde agricole etc c'est
pas des spams ministère fasse il est là
depuis l'identifier à la question de
l'europe et à la gestion du breakbeat
pour l'europe voilà et donc ce serait
une solution si vous voulez qu'il serait
ça serait un peu un maquereau à la
puissance 2 si vous voulez c'est à dire
que au lieu d'avoir une solution
populiste comme on peut dire voilà au
contraire on n'irait pas pour résoudre
pour choisir l ultra conformiste
européen après celui conformisme
européen là ça serait lutra conformisme
et c'est pourquoi pas c'est un propos
plan politique que tout est possible
alors matière soutient on a soit c'est
un mario draghi à la française ou un
maquereau puissance 2 alors moi je veux
dire ce soir c'est un maquereau avec
trop de plus donc je rejoins je rejoins
en réalité gérée sais pas si c'est un
compliment
le pas tant que ça oui voilà ce n'est
pas l'insulté suprême non mais mais pas
tant que ça effectivement le bal des
prétendants voit ses rangs s'élargir
effectivement quand deux conditions sont
réunies la première c'est que aucune
candidature de sa lumière un groupe
aucun leadership nay de soi et donc on
voit bien que il ya plusieurs options
possibles mais que ces options sont
multiples donc pourquoi pas l'hypothèse
michel barnier en plus et la deuxième
quand même condition pour qu'encore une
fois on sent une appétence généralisée
c'est que la victoire soit possible
alors très difficile à un an et demi de
la sphère de dire si la victoire est
possible
elle n'est sans doute pas impossible il
ya quand même encore à ce stade une
ligne de fracture qui existe en tout cas
dans la lecture du paysage politique
français
on a nos forces politiques
traditionnelles la gauche et la droite
les républicains et le ps qui sont des
forces localement très forte mais
nationalement nationalement exemple et
on a en face de ça aujourd'hui deux
forces qui ne pèse rien au plan local
le front national le rassemblement
national et la république en marche et
en revanche à ce stade dans tous les
sondages qui se succèdent sont ceux qui
ont vocation à composer le duo des
finalistes
voilà je ne sais pas si ce sera ça mais
on ne peut pas dire que du coup dans cet
espace là en fait michel barnier se
disent
j'y vais parce que de toute façon le
truc va nous tomber tout chaud dans la
touche au dans la main comme françois
fillon ou les autres pouvaient se le
dire après cinq années de françois
hollande qui laissait assez peu de
chances à la gauche de se voir réélire
donc la vire alors ensuite michel
barnier lui-même
c'est vrai qu'il a un cv relativement
impressionnant il a coché absolument
toutes les cases de ce que la vie
démocratique française propose
il a été député député européen sénateur
multi minina et il a fini double
commissaire européen puis négociateurs
du bric site donc son cv est très long
néanmoins je serai présent il me semble
il me semble mais je suis un observateur
- fin moins aguerris que géant mais il
me semble qu'ils n'étaient jamais
apparus jusqu'à lors comme un personnage
politique de premier plan
voilà de premier plan est ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui la star sait ne le
connaissent pas bien pas bien alors
qu'il a quand même été ministre des
affaires étrangères ministre des
affaires européennes ministre de
l'agriculture ministre de
l'environnement sous trois présidents
différents quand même mitterrand quand
il était à l'environnement avec balladur
a ensuite chirac est ensuite sarko donc
il a servi très longtemps sans arriver à
imprimer véritablement comme on dit
aujourd'hui
et si l'un prime aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on a beaucoup vu avec un niveau de
encore une fois un 2 2 quand même de
notoriété limité on l'a vu sur cette
affaire de break site et il est très
rare qu'un candidat en fait s'impose en
venant de l'extérieur
de l'extérieur c'est en fait de
l'étranger de l'europe ou d'ailleurs on
n'a jamais vu un président de la
république
en tout état de cause sous la vème
république se faire élire en étant une
espèce de d'électron libre
venus de l'étranger non investies dans
la politique nationale depuis un certain
nombre d'années
non mais au fond on peut se dire qu'elle
maniait le maquereau en 2017 se fait
élire beaucoup enfin à 10 ans en faisant
une campagne très axé aussi sur l'europe
très européen a en étant très très et de
secours de la ville étant déjà certains
disaient si risquées les français vers
urgent qu il a des deux profils se
ressemblent bon il ya un libéral est un
libéral européen avec cette petite
dimension un peu techno liée à son
passage par la commission européenne
évidemment quand on pense europe on
pense bureaucratie européenne a fortiori
quand on est pas un et pas on n'est pas
un élu du parlement de strasbourg et un
commissaire européen donc du côté de
l'administration bruxelloise
donc je ne suis pas sûr il a eu compris
ce côté pardon mais un peu beau gosse
que peut avoir macron mais avec encore
une fois à 30 ans de plus je je je
espace politique je vois si macron était
impuissante et peut-être que michel
barnier pour respecter la présente est
effectivement une sorte de joker c'est
la revanche d'une de l'ancien monde pour
le coup parce que il incarne
complètement l'ancien monde
ah oui parce que on peut bien compléter
son cv en rappelant que à la foi et à
l'image effectivement maintenant seul
homme de bruxelles si vous voulez mais
ce n'est absolument pas un technocrate
au départ effectivement non seulement il
a eu cette carrière ministérielle mais
il a été dit c'est en président du
conseil général 1
donc départementale désormais de la
savoie donc grc vraiment on peut pas
faire plus enraciné dans son terroir
en l'occurrence savoyard que cet homme
donc effectivement il a un cv magnifique
gertie part de son canton il va y arrive
à la commission européenne josé remonte
à faire on peut pas faire mieux que je
sais c'est absolument extraordinaire il
était ministre des affaires étrangères
par exemple personne personne ne s'en
souvient mais donc c'est merveilleux
c'est à dire qu'il arrive effectivement
à une politique qui serait a priori dans
ta production seront sous peu en savoir
assez proche de celle des bonnes
nouvelles macro mais avec un cv
totalement ancien monde
alors pour la droite pour l air plus
précisément ce serait un choix quand
même assez intéressant on voit bien que
l'actuel ment aux singes et j'ai fini
hier soir un excellent livre d'un député
l air que je saurais trop vous
recommander à savoir les liquidateurs
signé par olivier marleix hx1 est un
livre formidable qui est pas très hot
qui est assez sévères soient manuelles
macron est classé vert aussi sur l'union
européenne mais sans exclure que d'après
ce que j'ai vu
olimar l'efs n'a pas non plus fait enfin
bon vous verrez ça mais dans la presse
je crois que dans le figaro pour être
précis je crois qu'effectivement il ya
eu une réunion ce matin ce matin hier
matin je crois avec les deux les
relations sont pas forcément mauvaises
parce que la droite en fait aujourd'hui
n'est pas au second tour dans les
sondages elle ne l'a pas été en 2017
elle a été distancé très largement aux
européennes et donc elle est devant un
choix avant même de parler de choix
idéologiques
un choix on va dire simplement
électoraliste qui de kia va prendre la
place pour être au second tour alors
croiser les élections en troisième
position a parfois à 16% 16% par rapport
à 1
le second du 1er tour dans ces sondages
encore une fois très virtuel mais ça
donne il y est quand même est à 24 % 16
24% à presque un an et demi d'élections
tout c'est jouable
ces quatre points donc que je décide de
faire la droite est ce que et décide
d'aller conquérir une partie de
l'électorat maquereau ou une partie de
l'électorat leur aide pour être précis
est-ce qu'il va reconquérir ses
électeurs partis hors assemblée
nationale ou reconquérir les électeurs
partis plus récemment souvent chez la
république en marche et la barnier ça
serait un choix comment dirais-je
ça serait pas un candidat d'opposition
en macro ça sera un candidat de
substitution à maquereau ce sera en
quelque sorte une nouvelle balle si vous
voulez pour la même politique
c'est assez mal c'est ce qui m'intéresse
si vous voulez actuellement on verra
bien tout ça il ya tout il ya un nom qui
sortent toutes les deux semaines
actuellement mais ça c'est ce qui
m'intéresse dans les débats autour de la
candidature totalement virtuel pour
l'instant de michel barnier c'est de
voir justement où paf
les élus à l'air actuellement où est ce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils ont une marge de
manoeuvre alors nicole dit barnier
probablement un peu mou côté sécurité
immigration
on vous voit les préoccupations puisque
nicole points 0,6 j'imagine que vient
elle vient des alpes-maritimes et la
fraude un michel nil représente l'europe
quel grand nombre de français ne veut
plus entre les souverainistes et les
mondialistes qui veulent une autre
europe
il n'a aucune chance son côté chiraquien
parce que malgré tout vous hillion et
c'est quand même ça qui kills qui
l'incarnent représentants de la droite
modérée et ce qui peut pas mordre
jean marc marino l'a dit être un peu à
la place d'emmanuel macro mais également
mortes sur le centre gauche après tout
ça peut fonctionner les chiraquiens
c'était un rad soc qu'il a pu avoir
aussi il peut séduire une partie de la
gauche michel barnier oui alors non ça
vous paraît loin la police chirac
chiraquiens et de jeu c'est que la
gauche est très affaibli vraiment mais
si l'idée d'avoir été ministre de chirac
vous rend un cran un candidat crédible
pour pouvoir incarner les forces de
gauche de centre gauche de même mais
c'était sûrement s'agira d'un jeu je
crains qu'on soit un peu loin dans la 2
point de vue je rejoins quand même
l'analyse de jérôme sainte-marie a
fortiori parce que michel barnier fait
savoir depuis qu'il sème ses petites
graines là c'est que ces quelques jours
la sortie de son livre que ce qui
l'inquiète cosip ce qui l'inquiète
pardon au plus haut point c'est le
populisme le risque populiste c'est ça
qu'on voit bien quand même qu'il va
chausser en fait les les chaussures de
d'emmanuel mâcon et encore une fois
emmanuel macron mènent aujourd'hui une
politique qui me semble pour être
qualifié de droite devrait être modérée
et cetera peu importe mais même si sur
les questions sécuritaires on voit bien
que la gauche aura du mal quand même à
revenir vers emmanuel macron mais il
incarne une politique de droite
il a un électorat qui au fil du
quinquennat quand même c'est totalement
déplacé dans le centre de gravité s'est
totalement déplacé par la droite donc
emmanuel macron quand même locke le
couloir de droite aujourd'hui de manière
relativement indiscutable et que ce soit
en fait michel barnier ou xavier
bertrand ou quelqu'autre en réalité la
ferme va être compliqué encore une fois
à une exception près c'est que la
dernière année du quinquennat dit
emmanuel macron encore une fois
l'impuissance qui est tout à fait
possible son niveau de popularité reste
très correct reste très correct mais on
entend des clubs parallèle dans un
contexte dans un contexte de crise aussi
puissante la nôtre en réalité la
popularité du leader devrait être bien
supérieure emmanuel macron pardon
françois hollande ou nicolas sarkozy
dans des contextes de crise très aigu
avait bénéficié d'une popularité très
supérieure éphémère éphémère mais très
supérieur donc le socle des manuels
macron n'est pas si ce n'est pas si
stade accueillera son électorat et la
rendre on est l'acte son électorat est
là mais si la crise sanitaire le fait
dévisser et elle peut le faire dévisser
dans les prochains mois les crises
sanitaires et la crise sociale
rien ne dit qu'ils sont en situation
comme il l'a dit lui-même à brutus
d'ailleurs il ya quelques semaines qu'il
soit en situation de sur de sa santé
mentale
il a eu ses salles paris michel barnier
ci de là dessus le pari de se dire
chiche pour être le premier ministre
emmanuel macron on est jeune il est
totalement vain
devoir ans michel barnier quelqu'un qui
est à gauche ou à droite ça ne rompez
c'est un européen c'est à dire qu'il
sera là s'il était choisi sera là pour
mettre en application les réformes
demandées officiellement par la
commission européenne en échange des
prêts qui ont été faits notamment la
liquidation du système de santé français
faut le dire les choses clairement et
une privatisation
généralement on peut être européens de
gauche ou européen de droits non non à
l'europe libérale on peut être pourrons
nous encore une européens que sont nos
pays et on respecte la commission
européenne et quand la président de la
commission européenne parle moi je les
écoute je suis un bon européen et donc
là évidemment garder comme aller à
beaulieu et jérôme la commission
européenne alors mon nom tabou pas un
objet sur la commission européenne on
déborde ray et mais ça serait
intéressant mais on déborde juste donc
la question sur twitter est ce que
michel barnier est l'homme qui pourrait
qui peut sauver la droite
ben non à 82 81 2% vous estimez comme le
faisait interlocuteur qui n'est pas le
temps l'homme âgé palais le nombre de
votants
on regardera président je vous donnera
la réponse mais en tout cas voilà pour
l'instant en tout cas c'est pas l'homme
qui peut sauver la droite mais nous
c'est nous qui avons pu faire cette
émission merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
et à bientôt pour une prochaine émission
point de vue
[Musique]